following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at Walt
tech have prepared these educational
materials for you to better understand
the seven defining attributes that make
you special our next area of attention
is intelligence with all the talk of
physical survival in the wasteland you
may forget that sometimes it's survival
of the smartest an empty mind is a
vessel for knowledge and intelligence is
the key to unlocking opportunity and
adapting to your new world above ground
your advanced know how will grant you
access to new places and new
technologies space age isn't it
intelligent survivors are also more
inventive creating technological wonders
of their own note that the s in science
stands for safety and when the tables
are turned against you don't be afraid
to set aside your refined intelligence
for the raw instinct of survival
just don't lose your head advanced
learning in the field of intelligence
can offer even more benefits in this
modern age of wonder to start navigating
with technological ease keep blood where
it belongs by here and in creating more
potent chemical compounds from regularly
study your vault-tec provided materials
to prepare for survival and to answer
the question do you know what makes you
special
Oh